are you ready for the next game from the
team behind saints row well you can get
your hands on it fairly soon I'm Tony
and this is your mayhem filled GameSpot
news update if you're unfamiliar with
agents of mayhem here's the elevator
pitch your team of characters aren't
exactly heroes and you'll accomplish
most of your missions with a ton of
destruction using guns and gadgets and
unique abilities if that sounds good to
you you'll be happy to know it's coming
to ps4 Xbox one and PC on August 15th
and North America August 18th in Europe
and if you're curious developer volition
has said there's no Nintendo switch
version in the works but make sure
you're subscribed to GameSpot in case
anything changes yes agents of mayhem
lets you pick three agents at the start
of each mission but no the game is
single-player only you can read more
about that in our full preview and for
more explosive fun check out our awesome
Zelda April Fool's video on how to pilot
those mighty Guardians
[Music]
[Music]